Scooter headlines the polar sound
festival in vaasa finland it's freezing
outside but once this German techno trio
gets on stage the hall is sweltering
scooter is a big hit in the high north
I often play in colder regions
I'd love to prepare in the South of
France sometime I don't know why that is
it just seems to go with the music
somehow Finland's not even foreign for
us anymore we've performed here so often
we deserve a Finnish ID just like it did
in our 90s this is the scooter logo we
take this to every concert on scooters
latest and 18th album ace classic techno
is mixed with contemporary club sounds
the single toy is based on the melbourne
bounce style
spring needs a muzzle hit or miss
there's no point in always trying to
keep something alive and being so retro
we have a huge repertoire of classics
fast pieces and typical sciutto techno
pieces you have to at least try to
reinvent yourself from time to time and
redo the whole thing so it's in keeping
with the turns the driving force behind
the new sound is 25 year old fairy
spider a DJ and producer from Austria he
joined the long-standing team in 2014
sometimes they have an odd way of saying
things there are lots of things that
have no words for them especially music
productions but there are terms these
guys toss around as naturally as if they
were in the dictionary that describe a
particular sound or something scooter
bows the charts in 1994 with its first
hit hyper hyper
to feel
since then the group's had nearly 40
singles in the International charts
scooter is both loved and hated but its
recipe for success has worked right to
the present day fast beats well-known
melodies and a belting voice sometimes
it makes me laugh when people seriously
philosophize of the lyrics I think what
a load of nonsense I was some boy for
instant goes everywhere I go all the
ladies want to touch me
of course that's part wishful thinking
and part self ridicule musicians meet
fans backstage after 30 million album
sales in 23 years
scooter tries to stay close to expands
we're proud of our fans who have been
with us for years and new ones keeps
showing up that continues to the present
day for Cosette's
with a new album in the bag scooter will
soon be zipping back to Germany and off
to tour Britain and Russia
you